-Welcome back to the show,
and thank you for coming
on together.
I appreciate this.
Wayne, I was told you
have a gift for me,
which is -- You don't
have to give me a gift, but --
-I have a gift for you.
Little skateboard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is it...
Talk to me about this.
-That's my first
little Pro Model Deck.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-I want a skateboard.
I do want to get one, because --
but I don't know
even where to start.
-You got one.
That's the start right there.
-That's it?
-Yeah.
And a beginner can do this?
A beginner can use this?
-Yeah.
-Yeah?
-Mm-hmm.
-Like, what do I have to do
for -- Like, let's talk tricks.
-Let me show you.
You hold it like this and you --
-No, no, no, no, no, no!
That's how we use it,
but thank you, though.
I appreciate it. Thank you.
You guys have known each other
for a long time, right?
-Yeah.
Yeah, you were the --
[ Laughter ]
Well -- you're like,
"Yeah, we met backstage."
No, actually, you were the best
man at 2 Chainz's wedding.
-I was.
-We have a photo.
Here's a photo right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait. Wait. Can we look
at this picture one more time?
You have to stand on a couch
to reach the top of his --
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-That's really funny.
That's really funny.
He's a tall dude.
Yeah. But do you remember
when you first met,
or where did you first meet?
2 Chainz?
-You remember?
-I do.
-Where was it?
-I think it was Atlanta.
-Yeah, it was
definitely Atlanta.
Yeah, it was the "A."
And he came through.
He came through the studio.
-Yeah.
-And, actually,
we were friends --
I mean, once we linked up,
we were friends from there.
Just same type of attitude,
cool,
but I didn't know he rapped
at the time.
-What did you think he did?
-He was just
a cool dude from Atlanta.
-Just a cool dude from Atlanta?
-I knew he played ball
and I knew he graduated
from college
and stuff like that.
-How did you end up
to going in the studio?
Just --
-[ Clears throat ]
-Yeah, it was -- We -- It was --
-Tell him. Tell him.
-[ Sighs ]
-What the hell is going on?
-Uh...Wayne wanted cannabis,
and...
[ Laughter ]
-I apologize. Okay.
I'm sorry. Okay.
-You made me say that.
-But I didn't know you were
going to go there. I apologize.
-Yeah.
-I didn't look at the notes.
I will stick to the script.
I'm sorry. Okay. I apologize.
-Yeah, Wayne wanted --
-Okay.
And you knew where to get some.
-Yeah. There you go.
-Okay. Now it's making sense.
That's making sense.
-And, like he said --
-And so every time
I would go to Atlanta
and I wanted to speak about
that one thing,
I would always call this guy
to talk about that.
And one day --
one day, we were in the studio.
He would always
just come through the studio.
And one day, we were there,
and we said something
about music.
And he --
It was something you said --
You said something
about Ludacris?
-Well, yeah, I told you --
I was like, you know --
I'd been hanging around a while
and I told you,
"You know, I rap, too."
And you was like, "For real?"
We was on the way to the studio.
We was actually --
I think Mr. G was driving.
And I said, "You don't mind
if I, you know --"
You said,
"Yo, go on and play it."
And I played, and you said,
"Boy, y'all can rap, boy."
-I know. Yeah.
He's like, "Well,
what Luda doing with y'all?"
And I was like, "You know,
we're getting it together."
But that's when I first felt
comfortable enough to tell you
I was, you know,
doing the music thing.
-And then you just started
working and you go, "That's it.
We hit it off.
We're got to work together."
-The moment he said he rapped
and the moment I heard it,
like he said,
we was on the way to the studio.
We got to the studio, and I did
this hook for the song.
-Yeah, "Duffel Bag Boy."
-"Duffel Bag Boy."
And the rest is history.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are we all Virgos?
-Libra.
-No, he didn't make it.
-Oh, you didn't make it.
But we're very close.
'Cause I know our birthdays
are all the same --
well, around the same.
I'm September 19th. You're...
-I'm the 12th.
-And I'm 27th.
-27th. I celebrated.
I had a nice dinner
with my wife and kids.
What did you do?
Wayne, what did you do?
-Me?
-Yeah.
-I ran out -- I got to run out
of the tunnel with
the Green Bay Packers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait. That's -- Alright. Here.
That is true, but how did you
end up doing that?
This is real.
[ Laughter ]
Dude, how do you end up
doing that?
-Me and the coach, Matt LaFleur,
are real, real, real
good friends.
And I'm a huge Green Bay Packer
fan since forever and a day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do have any connection
to Green Bay?
-That's my connection.
-Okay.
Your connection is
that you know him.
-Oh, no, you mean to --
That I'm a huge fan?
I've been a huge fan.
I was a huge fan
before Matt was coach, now.
But you're not from Green Bay?
-No. I'm from New Orleans.
-Yeah.
-So you're from New Orleans.
-And you just enjoy the
Green Bay Packers.
-I love them.
-Really?
-Yes.
-Why?
-When I was younger,
I think it was like '95, '96,
they won the Super Bowl
in New Orleans.
And when you win the Super Bowl,
the quarterback gets put
on the cover of "Madden"
the next year and all that,
so I was hooked.
And, so, my dad --
he went to the Super Bowl game.
He came back home
with memorabilia,
and it was all, "Green Bay
champs, Green Bay champs."
In the hood -- There's towels
and cups and stuff like that.
In the hood, that's not stuff
you, like, throw away.
You actually use that every day.
So every day --
You know what I'm saying?
Every day, I'm using the
"Green Bay champs" cup.
I'm showering
with the Green Bay towel.
I'm a Green Bay fan.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is a fantastic --
That's a fantastic story.
Fan for life.
-2 Chainz, what did you do
on your birthday?
-I bought a lawnmower
and a strip club.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah, yeah, I bought a --
-You bought a lawnmower...
-And a strip club.
-...and a strip club.
Okay. So, we had
similar birthdays,
the three of us there.
Wow! Wait. So, what made
you want to buy --
Let's start with the lawnmower,
yeah.
-Alright, so, I have a rather
large yard and I pay people --
I've always paid --
So, I've lived in apartments
my whole life.
Then I became a rapper
and stayed in -- got me a house.
And then I had money,
so I paid people
to do everything for me,
like most rich people do.
And then I woke up and I said,
"You know what?
I've never
cut the grass before."
And I felt like maybe
I hadn't crossed over
the threshold of manhood.
And so I woke up
and I got me a John Deere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A Zero-Turn.
-You got a John Deere
and a strip club
in the same week.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That is unbelievable.
That is a great story.
And the strip club open?
-Yeah. It's called Candyland.
It's in Atlanta.
Make sure you check us out.
Yeah. Needless to say,
it's for adults, you know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. No.
What can we say about the album,
"Welcome 2 ColleGrove"?
How about the name, ColleGrove?
-I'm from College Park.
-I'm from Hollygrove.
-And we combined the names,
and it's called The Grove,
so it's like we created
our own,
you know, universe,
our own space.
-And you're doing
a song for us tonight.
-Yes, we are.
-And I really appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys are two of the most
talented guys in the business.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate this.
-Thank you.
-You guys,
2 Chainz and Lil Wayne.
When we come back,
they're performing "Presha"
off their new album,
"Welcome 2 ColleGrove."
Stick around, everybody.